foreign
my name is Alexander Mueller I've been a
part of the Yuma farming Community for
about 12 years now and in the last two
years
two and a half years
seeing what's happening at the border
has been pretty alarming in terms in
relation to the eight years prior where
it was
you know you border patrol sits at the
border they they see somebody cross they
apprehend them they bring them the
station and then do whatever they need
to do now you're seeing
50 at a time 25 at a time 75 at a time
and you're seeing the whole world
represented in
um it's alarming to say the least
hey Gaza partner and Barclay company of
Arizona
fifth generation Family Farm we farmed
several thousand acres
um
the ground isn't exactly butting up to
the Border but we're within a half mile
of the Border in a lot of places
and we've gotten a fair amount of
traffic through
and around our fields and through the
whole entire Yuma Valley
foreign
it opens it up to more Farm ground for
them to walk across and we can't have
unauthorized people in our Fields
everything we grow
um
is eaten fresh within two weeks we cut
it cool it and ship it and it's consumed
within two weeks and everything most
everything we grow
isn't cooked so it doesn't have a kill
station it's fresh produce
border patrol knows that there's more
and more people coming to these points
there's a couple points here where
they're being flooded
there's obviously a food safety concern
because our fields are monitored and
audited and and tested you know for
different pathogens and you can't have
people walking through the field if
there's somebody that walks into our
field and we don't know about why we put
up
flags and kind of Mark it out and we
won't Harvest that and that hits the
bottom line you know
when you eat a salad from the middle of
November through the middle of April
this is where it comes from anywhere in
the continental United States we spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars just on
our farm
for food safety which is trying to keep
animals out
people out of fields
all to prevent
uh foodborne illness
when you have
12 or 1300 people a day Crossing in Yuma
in the border patrol at the beginning of
this didn't have enough
people to
take them all
to the bar patrol station they started
walking and they walked through these
fields that we spend
anywhere from five to ten thousand
dollars an acre to grow and you start
having people walk through those fields
so now you start
failing food safety audits
there is no insurance in the produce
business this is Las Vegas every day
so you eat that
last December there was 30 Haitians
living in the middle of a field for a
week and they wouldn't leave and so you
know that they had to go to the bathroom
somewhere so they had to destroy some
celery
that cost about ten thousand bucks an
acre and they to grow it and they had to
disk 10 acres of it so there's a hundred
thousand dollar loss right there
and this is the largest humanitarian
disaster we've had in this country and
part of the country is happy that it's
happening I can't I don't get why
it's not sustainable
it's not good for the country it's
really easy there's a few gaps close
that Gap close some of the gaps down
here
and let the border patrol do their jobs
again
I'm not some crazy alarmists conspiracy
whatever this is really happening
and this is produce that we're growing
for the country this is
for the whole country and uh it should
be protected